you might be wondering why you'd want to
use google sheets to web scrape well
here i've got a giant table of apple
species and by the time this sentence is
over i'm going to web scrape the entire
thing from scratch using google sheets
with just one line of code
web scraping from google sheets isn't
always the best solution because it
requires some level of messing around
but it can be a really fast solution
given the right circumstances
so my goal for this video is to give you
a broad overview of how web scraping
with sheets works there are four main
commands import html
import data import feed and import xml
we're going to cover the first three in
this video but we'll cover import xml in
a future video because it's kind of
tricky to work with so let's get started
so the first command we're going to
cover
is import html which allows you to
scrape both tables and lists
so i've got some data here from this
wikipedia page a list of earthquakes and
it has a few different tables on the
page
but the one i want are the largest
earthquakes by country or territory
so the first thing i need to do is
figure out which table index this is on
the page
because there are a lot of different
tables here i need to figure out which
one this is
so i've got some code for you in the
description that you're going to go
ahead and copy once you're on the page
you can right click
go to inspect open up this console
window and
paste this line of code and essentially
it'll pull out all the different tables
on the page
and as you hover over them it'll start
highlighting different tables that are
actually on your web page
like i mentioned i want to grab this
table of the largest earthquakes so once
i pasted that
line of code i'm going to go ahead and
hover over these different table rows
until i get the one that i want to be
highlighted and we see here that the
index number on the left
is three so we just have to remember
that number but now we can go ahead and
open up a new google sheet so i'm going
to type sheets.new which will quickly
bring me a new untitled spreadsheet this
is a little tip you can also do docs.new
or slides.new to open up a new google
doc or new slide but anyway now i can
call that import
html command and it's going to take in
three arguments so the first
is the url of the website so i'll grab
that next is either a table or list
depending on what you're trying to
scrape so here i'm scraping a table and
then last is that index number
we figured out that it was index three
that highlighted the table we want so
we'll put
three right in here once you hit enter
it should take a few seconds to load
your data but it'll suddenly all appear
inside of your spreadsheet now we could
be done at this point and just download
it as a csv
put it in our python and do whatever
text cleaning and analysis we need to do
but what's great about google sheets is
it does have a lot of functionality for
doing text cleaning and data cleaning
so right now our magnitude and date
columns look kind of messy so what we're
going to do
is before we start modifying them is hit
command a to grab all of our text
we're going to command c to copy it and
then do command shift v
to paste just the text values we're
first going to go to our date column
which you can see is kind of messed up
right now and
format it as a date which should fix a
lot of that for this magnitude column
right now the numbers aren't super clean
we've got some text down here some
dashes what we're going to do is create
a new column on the right we're actually
going to format this
to text first just plain text we're
going to call this magnitude dot
cleaned we're going to use our regex
extract function
to first select this column and we just
want to grab
a number that might have a period and
then another number right after it
we can double click on this and you can
see it populates
our column with the magnitudes and we
could continue to clean this up or do
more analysis
but i think you get the picture so
import html doesn't just work on tables
it also works on lists
although i will say it's a little less
useful so here i've got a recipe for
some noodles and let's just say i want
to grab
the ingredients and the directions into
my google sheet well i'm going to follow
a similar process i'm going to start by
grabbing that code from before
except i'm going to change the table to
be ul comma ol which stands for
unordered list or ordered list
here we have an unordered list these are
just bullet points and down here we have
an ordered list but again this will be
in the description
so i'll go ahead right click and inspect
go to the console window and paste this
line of code and like i said i want to
grab the ingredients and the steps to
make it
so i'll hover over these different rows
to figure out
ingredients we see that's number 14 and
then if i scroll down
steps to make it is 15. so i'll go back
over to our spreadsheet and we'll call
the import html command again we'll pass
in the url as our first argument now we
pass in list as the second argument and
again we pass in our index so we'll
start with 14 to get the ingredients so
we've got our ingredients i'm going to
go ahead and expand the column
and i'll copy this paste it here but now
replace it with 15
to get our directions so i guess this
could be practical if you had a lot of
different
recipe urls that all followed the same
standard procedure
but that's honestly pretty unlikely so
you can see how this would be a little
less useful since you have to manually
figure out the index now ideally you
would use one of these id
tags to figure out what are the
ingredients or what's the main recipe
and you can actually do that with the
import xml command
which i'll touch on in a later video but
for the time being if you're looking for
a more robust method i'd recommend
checking out my tutorial series on web
scraping with r where i cover a few
different examples so now we're going to
move on to the next command which is
import data and that allows you to
scrape csv or tsv files directly into
your spreadsheet so i've got this csv
file from github that i found
i'm going to go ahead and go to the raw
just so we have the actual csv
file and i'll copy this link go back to
our google sheets and then
write this line of code import data and
paste our link so when i hit enter it'll
take some time because this is a longer
csv
file but eventually it'll populate my
whole sheet with all the data and i
mentioned earlier how
google sheets is great because you can
do a bit of text cleaning or data
cleaning well it can also
make some charts really easily so here i
had some population data and if i wanted
to visualize what this looks like
over time i can make a new chart i'll
set the x axis to year
aggregate the data make it a line chart
and just like that we have our
population every time so pretty easy to
do and then the last command we're going
to look at from google sheets
is import feed which can scrape an rss
or atom feed directly into your
spreadsheet so here i've got the nasa
rss feed they have one for breaking news
so i'll go ahead and open this up i can
copy this link
go back to google sheets and write
import deed paste our feed in
and again it'll take a few seconds to
load but eventually the feed will
populate into our spreadsheet and we'll
be able to see
all of our data here now again i don't
know how useful or practical these
commands would be
for you personally but i think it's
worth knowing that the functionality
exists and i think that there are
certainly some scenarios if you have the
right type of data where google sheets
can really be helpful so again i'm going
to cover that last import xml command in
another video because it can be pretty
powerful although it is pretty confusing
to use but anyway thanks for watching
and i'll catch you in the next one